so we have three different function
definitions here this is f of x in blue
here we map between different values of
t and what g of t would be so you could
view this as as a definition of g of t
and here we map from x to h of x so for
example when x is equal to three
h of x is equal to zero when x is equal
to one h of x is equal to two and
actually let me number this one two
three
just like that now what i want to do in
this video is introduce you to the idea
of composing functions now what does it
mean to compose functions well that
means to build up a function by
composing one function
of other functions or or i guess you can
think of nesting them what do i mean by
that well let's think about what it
means to evaluate what does it mean to
evaluate f of not x
but we're going to evaluate f of
actually let's just start with a little
warm up let's evaluate f of
g of
g
of 2.
now what do you think this is going to
be and i encourage you to pause this
video and think about it on your own
well it seems kind of daunting at first
if you're not very familiar with the
notation but we just have to remember
what a function is a function is just a
mapping from one set of numbers to
another so for example when we're saying
g of 2 that means take the number 2
input it into the function g
and then you're going to get an output
which we are going to call g of 2
g of 2. now we're going to use that
output g of 2 and then input it into the
function f
so we're going to input it into the
we're going to input into the function f
and what we're going to get is f of
the thing that we inputted f of g of 2.
f of g of 2. so let's just take this
step by step what is g of 2
well when t is equal to 2
g of 2 is negative 3.
so g of 2 is negative 3
and so when i put negative 3
into f what am i going to get well i'm
going to get
negative 3 squared
negative 3 squared minus 1 which is 9
minus 1 which is going to be equal to 8.
so this right over here is equal to 8. f
of g of 2
is going to be equal to 8.
now what would using that same exact
logic what would f of
f of h of 2 be
f of
h
of 2b and once again i encourage you to
pause the video and think about it on
your own
well let's think about it this way
instead of doing it using these kind of
this little diagram
here everywhere you see the input is x
so whatever you do at the end whatever
the input is you squared n minus 1. here
the input is h of 2. and so we're going
to take the input which is h of 2
and we're going to square it
and we're going to square it and then
we're going to subtract and we're going
to subtract 1. so f of h of 2 is h of 2
squared minus 1.
now what is h of 2
when x is equal to 2 h of 2 is 1.
so h of 2 is 1
so since h of 2 is equal to 1.
this simplifies to 1 squared minus 1.
well that's just going to be 1 minus 1
which is equal
which is equal to
0. and we could have done it with the
the diagram way we could have said hey
we're going to input 2
into h
and put 2 into h if you input 2 into h
you get 1. so that is h of 2 right over
here so that is h of 2. and then we're
going to input that into f
and then we're going to input that
into f
which is going to give us
f of one f of one is one squared minus
one which is zero
which is 0. so this right over here is f
of h of 2.
h of 2 is the input into f so the output
is going to be f of our input
f of
h of 2.
now we can go even further let's do a
composite let's compose three of these
let's compose three of these functions
together so let's take
well i don't know let's take
g of
let's take and i'm doing this on the fly
a little bit so i hope it's a good
result g let me switch the order g of f
of
g of f of
f of
and let me just think about this for one
second
so that's going to be g of f of
and let's take h of g of f of 2 just for
fun
h of so now we're really doing a triple
composition
so there's a bunch of ways we could do
this one way is to just try to evaluate
what is
what is f of 2
well f of 2
is going to be equal to two squared
minus one it's going to be four minus
one or three
so this
is going to be equal to
three now what is g of three
g of three
is when t is equal to three g of three
is four
so g of three
this whole thing
is four
f of two is three g of three is four
what is h of 4
well we can just look back to our
original graph here when x is 4 h of 4
is negative 1.
so h of g of f of 2
is just equal to
negative 1. so hopefully this makes you
somewhat familiar with how to evaluate
the composition of functions